you a you're in a couple of films I am
you're Granberg greenbook mm-hmm
do you always play the Italian guy right
now yes yes what's the other movie
you're the Irishman oh that's gonna be a
big deal that's what Scorsese De Niro
Bluto it's a Z yeah did you audition for
Scorsese so I come down here the the the
they gave me an option the casting
director said either you send in a tape
from Los Angeles or you come to New York
City and audition in the room I said I'm
going on my own dime I'm coming to New
York to work with Scorsese yes the
ultimate so I walk in she goes you're
looking really good for this okay
Scorsese saw your comedy looking really
good that's all you have to tell me is
I'm looking good and I'm in my head that
said yeah I get it
hey Jake sit they jinx if they told me
you got a lot of work to do for this
part oh man let's do this if you tell me
I'm almost a shoo-in so long story short
the the casting director called my agent
said he was good but not consistent let
him do it over on tape and I'll and I'll
look at that and if I like that I'll
show Scorsese are you something for this
I mean my god so I said fine I'll do it
III relished in the second chance and I
did it I sent it in they showed the
Scorsese he's like I I like it I don't
like it for that part I like him for
another part and boom I got the role the
first day I'm acting with De Niro and De
Niro and Pesci same scene oh my god boy
they at least gracious enough to kind of
say hey a little bit you should you
should relax don't worry about I didn't
know again I don't know if they know I'm
a comedian I don't know if they even
know what's going on so I'm on the set
De Niro walks in he comes up to me and
goes hey doing good things
you're doing very good things all right
that's an icebreaker that was gracious
yeah
that she came up very sweet how you
doing nice to meet you so I can't
imagine a more harrowing experience than
you know you're not someone who's done a
lot of nothing now you stand in there
with Scorsese De Niro and Pesci yeah
that's gotta be [ __ ] nuts nuts so I
got Scorsese coming out we're gonna
rehearse the scene just us four we're
all out there and if you [ __ ] up you
know didn't yours who is this ask what
I'm saying I live in fear oh I don't
live in the positivity I live in I could
get fired at any minute
is it an intense scene like a big acting
scene yeah this is a big scene this is a
word the Copacabana and I'm going
head-to-head with De Niro
oh my see this movie when the [ __ ] is
this thing coming out this year I
haven't seen anything I haven't seen
even the scenes I was in I didn't see
it's that it's not like they all cut and
I go back to ever like the idiot Allah
does to guys probably do they're all in
a huddle right and it's like a
collaboration Tin vited and you're the
blue she stands over there while they
collaborate